just how accurate do you think the quote
is history doesn't repeat itself but it
often rhymes
it's doubly inaccurate because first of
all it it wasn't what Mark Twain said
people usually attribute it to Mark
Twain of Huckleberry Finn Fame but
actually twin didn't say that he said
something much more complex about
history being like a kaleidoscope
remember those kaleidoscopes who used to
have as kids and and the pattern shifts
but there's a kind of regularity to it
that's what Twain actually said not uh
that it doesn't repeat itself but it
Rhymes and it's inaccurate also because
history doesn't repeat itself in the way
that we would like it to be very nice if
it had that kind of uh predictable
pattern
but in truth uh it it doesn't and you
can try to to look for patterns uh but
you'll frequently be disappointed and
that that I think is one of the most
important lessons that I've learned
history is is not regular and cyclical
and predictable it's actually pretty
noisy and and and volatile and
unpredictable and that's that's what
makes my life interesting I I can't tell
you with any certainty what's going to
happen in the next seven days never mind
the next 10 years does that limit the
lessons that we can learn from history
then given that as you've said it's not
as cyclical it's not got this sort of
recurrent theme
I I think it means that we've got to
learn rather different lessons from the
ones we want to learn we want cookie
cutter lessons as in if a dictator is
elected there will be World War II that
that kind we love those simple lessons
and we hate being told actually there
were dictators who didn't start wars
they're not all Hitler so we have to
look for a different approach to
learning lessons instead of wanting
cookie cutter lessons we should realize
that the most important lesson of
history is that it is as unpredictable
and non-linear as sport
it's not a story
the kind that you read to your kids with
a beginning a middle and a happy ending
it's it's as unpredictable uh as a as a
game but but it's more open-ended it's
like a game of football that never stops
or a game of chess That Never Ends where
the board is so large that there never
can be a conclusive winner and if one
recognizes that that's the lesson that
there's lots of contingency and chaos
and that even small decisions kind of
massive consequences and big decisions
can have no consequences learn that
about the historical process will lead
us I think to make better decisions in
the present because it will get us away
from what I would call bad lesson
learning so bad lesson learning takes
the form of uh just to give you one
example
uh the United States
deciding to invade Iraq uh and believing
that it would be quite easy to establish
democracy there because American troops
would be welcomed in Baghdad like the
liberators of Paris uh towards the end
of World War II that was a terrible bad
lesson of History uh the right lesson
was it's extremely difficult if you
topple a dictator to establish a stable
government in the ruins of the dictators
regime it can be done but it's really
expensive and it takes ages so I think
there are lessons to be learned from
history but we tend to We tend to try to
learn simple ones and that's where we go
wrong is part of this due to the fact
that you identified the the neatness of
a story the beginning the middle the end
this nice closure uh it's something
that's sufficiently familiar that it
feels like an old pair of leather shoes
but it is the job of historians a lot of
you know popular modern historians to
make stories compelling they need to be
able to Captivate the reader so is this
problem in some part laid at the feet of
you and your colleagues for making
history so compelling and and familiar
to us in a narrative sense somehow well
if you're writing a history book there
is certainly an expectation that it
should be ideally as readable as a novel
I'll give you an example Orlando 5g's
wrote an excellent history of the
Russian Revolution called a people's
tragedy
when you frame an historical episode as
a tragedy the reader kind of knows what
to expect it's not going to end well
there'll probably be bodies all over the
stage uh at some point towards the end
so that's fair enough and it's a good
history of the Russian revolution
revolution one of the best in English
but it it slightly lulls the reader into
thinking that there could only really be
one outcome one sequence of events that
it was sort of bound to produce this
dysfunctional totalitarian regime that
was bound to last until about the late
1980s and then fall apart oh the
inevitability is baked into the framing
we know the story and so we kind of read
it with this sense that it's all
destined to fail
but to fail over a prolonged 70-year
period And I think that's not right I
think there were times when the Russian
Revolution could have been aborted the
Bolsheviks could have lost uh there were
times when the Russian Revolution could
have led all the way to World War III
think of the Cuban Missile Crisis there
are lots of different ways this story
could have ended and I really love
history that keeps that sense of the
possible Alternatives alive I think it's
better to read history as a series of
forking paths with a keen awareness of
other Futures that might have happened
rather than to think the minute you pick
up the book
oh there's going to be a Revolution in
Russia the romanov's going to be
overthrown liberalism will fail the
Bolsheviks will seize power things will
go to bad for to worse understand to
know the story
and then to read it as if it's a novel I
think is is actually a big Pitfall much
better to be aware that they are
constant turning points moments when it
could have gone differently Stalin could
have been arrested he thought he was
going to be arrested at one point when
uh Hitler invaded
uh this is an astonishing moment because
Stalin had been completely certain he
wouldn't
uh and ignored all the intelligence uh
that he got saying the Germans are going
to invade the Soviet Union ignored it
all said it was all propaganda we would
say fake news
uh and so when Germans actually did
invade and the Red Army was in total
disarray not least because he purged or
killed all its most competent officers
Stalin retreated to his Dutcher in a
kind of state of panic and wondered when
his colleagues in the Pollock Bureau
would turn up and arrest him as he'd
arrested many of his colleagues in the
past they did turn up and he kind of
expected them to put on the handcuffs
and instead they kind of said please
come back to Moscow we we can't actually
function without uh being terrorized by
you so that was just one of the many
moments in the history of the Soviet
Union that might have produced a
completely different outcome because I
think if Stalin had been arrested
then it's hard to imagine that the
Soviet Union wouldn't have lost World
War II uh there would have been a kind
of political vacuum that's a different
20th century right there and in my work
and I've been doing this now for more
decades than I like to count I
constantly try to keep the reader aware
there are these other paths that we
could have gone down just as right now
today our lives your life my life
everybody who's listening's lives they
could go in a completely different
direction because of some disaster that
strikes I get hit by a car Crossing Park
Avenue and everything's different from
that moment on just because I wasn't
paying attention when I crossed the road
that's the historical reality that we we
have to keep reminding ourselves of
why is it the case given that Human
Nature has been relatively stable for
all of recorded history it's been stable
it's been stable with 120 000 years
and group dynamics
seems sometimes to reliably be similar
as well why is it the case then that we
don't have this cyclical nature to
history is it the uh disproportionate
effective chance is it the fact that as
you mentioned a lot of very large things
can occur due to very small inputs what
is it that's causing this fractured
fragmented Kaleidoscope rather than a
nice smooth wheel yeah well you've said
something very important which is that
there are certain constant features of
human nature and that is right which is
why we can understand facilities
it's why we can understand Shakespeare
uh The Human Condition particularly when
it comes to Love and Death and power
that hasn't really changed much even
Although our lifespans are much longer
than the people of thucydides time and
the nature of life has radically altered
not least because of of Technology
so there's something very important
about that which is why it's worth
studying history because if if two
cities was just unintelligible to us and
and Shakespeare made no sense well we
couldn't possibly learn a thing from the
experience of the past we like reading
about aliens but they're not aliens
they're they're people that's that's a
really important thing which when you
come to ponder it's remarkable how
amazing is that the people who were born
thousands of years ago when life
expectancy was in the 20s can express
themselves in ways that we can
understand in our radically altered
world I never cease to be amazed by the
fact that we have any connection at all
with the people of the past
now there's a critical difference
that I've just hinted at which is that
the there is this technological
innovation that really starts to
accelerate from the late 18th century
and and makes the world different uh
decade after decade and and and in ways
that are quite uh unpredictable uh
there's the exponential growth in living
standards that comes from the Industrial
Revolution but there's other things also
happening uh the kind of unintended
consequences of of uh labor-saving
technology so that's part of the reason
that history doesn't repeat itself
because for example once you have
nuclear weapons War can never be quite
the same again uh and so you can't
really perfectly learn from 1914 what to
do in 2024 because in 1914 although they
could they could risk a massive
conventional War there wasn't the
possibility of utter planetary
destruction
but there's an even more important Point
than that that I want to make and that
is disasters
we may be kind of the same Homo sapiens
as the ancient Athenians but we inhabit
a planet where all kinds of random stuff
happens and we can't control it uh the
disasters that constantly punctuate
history uh massive volcanic eruptions
enormous earthquakes
cataclysmic floods are plagues all that
kind of natural stuff and then the
man-made calamities as we like to call
them like Wars these things happen in a
totally non-cyclical way there's just no
pattern to the incidence of large-scale
uh organized violence uh there's no
pattern to the incidence of of massive
volcanic activity and that's why there's
no cycle of History because while we may
be trying in our unchanging human way to
achieve power and love and all the rest
of it we're doing it in a chaotic
environment and we just don't know
what's going to happen next but I'm
absolutely sure that when you plot all
the different shocks that nature and we
ourselves inflict on the planet there's
no cycle there there can't be it just
statistically isn't isn't observable
I think one of the reasons that people
like and are comforted by the idea that
history repeats itself or Echoes is it
gives us a sense of control
it it makes us believe that we have a
prediction engine that we can if we read
enough of the past we can accurately
work out what's going to go on in the
future
that's right and political scientists
and social scientists especially
economists
feel that if they can only model the
historical process then they will be
able to project
the future with some uh degree of
certainty
and this is a constantly disappointing
exercise but it doesn't stop them trying
and to see just how hard it is let's
look back on the predictions of uh just
of the economy over the last uh 20 years
or so
Nobel prize winning economists
have been wrong again and again about
our major economic shocks from the
financial crisis that began uh in 2008
through to the pandemic there's still an
ongoing debate about what caused uh the
big inflation surge uh of uh 2021 2022
uh there were eminent economists Laden
down with honors who were sure that the
there would be a transitory inflation
episode in the wake of the pandemic and
the only way they've been able to stay
uh stay true to that hypothesis is by
changing the meaning of the word
transitory over and over and over again
so you you look back and you realize
even now
the best paid economists in the world
here in New York and Wall Street the the
people with the most Kudos at the
international monetary fund uh they do a
terribly bad job even of predicting what
growth and inflation will be 12 months
from now the Federal Reserve employs
some really smart people they have phds
it's really hard to get a job there uh
it doesn't pay that well but once you've
been at the fed you get hard by the
hedge funds and you make tons of money
so this is very competitive and they
were so crazily wrong about where
interest rates would be right now two
years ago they were like 500 basis
points off they were wildly wildly wrong
and that was just over a two-year time
Horizon so we would love history to be
predictable so that we could just apply
our model and say oh here's the fiscal
policy here's the monetary policy this
will be the inflation rate and this will
be interest rate we keep trying to do
that but then you go back and this is
what we as stories do you go like hey
let's see how those projections actually
did let's take a look and I'll give you
a good example the Congressional budget
office Congressional budget offers
constantly tries to project what the
federal debt will be in relation to U.S
gross domestic product
and it does this exercise on a highly
regular basis and it's always wrong
and not just a bit wrong it's kind of
wildly wrong it's been it's
underestimated the direction of the debt
consistently for 20 plus years now and
they'll keep publishing those
projections and they'll keep being
discussed and people will write op-eds
about them and go on TV to talk about
them but the truth is they'll continue
to be wrong because there's something
fundamentally
flawed in the model the model is a
simplification
but it is such a big simplification of
reality of the historical process that
it's basically always wrong
there's a concept called the [__]
asymmetry principle which is it takes
far less energy to produce [__] than
it does to refute it therefore the world
is filled with unrefuted [__] and
right especially TV especially on TV and
it must be said probably on podcasts too
though we have contributing we are
contributing to that asymmetry of
[__] right now I I'm trying my best
to to be anti-bull shirt
um it's like kind of antimatter and the
the key to to anti-bull [__] is that it
is much less it doesn't go viral it just
doesn't go I mean anti-bull [__] it's
it's it's just doomed not to go viral on
Twitter and so you carry on doing your
best but you will always be you will
always be swamped by the [__] yeah
so
give me have you got two examples of a
scenario which if we were using this
sort of typical cyclical very nice and
neat approach with history you would
have said well this happened in the past
and this happened after the past and
they were broadly similar in terms of
inputs but that the outcomes were
unbelievably far apart is there an
illustrative example that you can think
of there
well a good uh source for examples is uh
the history of Empire
because people always want to use the
history of Empire to think about
American power
and so every decade there will be at
least one book and usually more than one
saying we are Rome you know we are in
the predicament of the Roman uh Empire
and our Decline and fall uh is
inevitable because we are decadent and
we like bread and we like circuses
except we have burgers and and American
football but it's that that's the thesis
and it's always kind of reliable if
you're a publisher you'll sell books uh
with the we are Rome uh hypothesis
uh and of course history is basically
the history of Empires it is mostly
about Empires even although we like to
tell ourselves it's really about nation
states nation states are basically quite
a recent invention most of History if
you just mean all in of recorded
histories about Empires because the
empires do stuff and they have pretty
good record keeping and that's that's
most of what we study so we have a
pretty good sample size of Imperial rise
uh and Zenith and Decline and fall
uh because Empires do that that that's
why most of the empires that ever
existed don't exist today including the
British Empire
and the French Empire all the other
Empires that uh that existed when our
grandparents were around
so it ought to be possible you'd have
thought to have some kind of general
theory of Imperial rise and and fall and
that ought to be a cycle of history that
you know we can work with and then we
could say oh okay so the United States
has reached uh it's past the Zenith and
it's now in the kind of late phase so we
should we should expect Decline and fall
to begin in 2028
the problem is that when you sit down
with all the empires that ever existed
the first thing you realize is there's
this massive discrepancy uh in duration
that the Nazi Empire
barely made it past a decade and in fact
if you only start counting from the
reoccupation of the Rhineland it's not
even that
and the Roman Empire is like a thousand
years
so Gibbon's great Decline and fall of
the Roman Empire covers a millennium
so you don't know I mean sure the
empires rise and they have a good good
kind of period of dominance and then
they Decline and fall but is it going to
happen in a few years or is it going to
take a few centuries there's no way of
knowing and that's why the temptation to
draw analogies with past Empires is is
quite quite hazardous it's always
possible to find a case and say oh you
see here we are we're just about where
Britain was in pick a decade this is
I've done this myself I did this for The
Economist just before the US abandoned
Afghanistan I wrote a piece of The
Economist saying ah the US is beginning
to look a bit like Britain between the
wars kind of too much debt kind of
overextended
um and I use that analogy to make the
argument that the US is is getting to be
where Britain was in the mid-20th
century overstretched it's not a new
argument
and as part of my anti-bull [__] Mission
I would say it's only one of a dozen
analogies I could have used and I could
equally well have said that that the
United States is where the British
Empire was in the 1820s
and in the 1820s Britain was going
through a rough patch had beaten
Napoleon had a ton of debt all kinds of
social problems lots of deep division
polarization I could I could have
written a piece saying that's where the
US is today
and the good news is that after Britain
came out of the 1820s it expanded its
Empire uh over the next 100 years almost
uninterruptedly and ruled the world
there's no way of knowing which is the
right analogy you just pick uh you pick
the one that that suits your
journalistic purpose and off you go but
if I'm being absolutely uh brutally
honest
uh there's there's no real way to be
sure which analogy is the right one that
that's that's the that's the terrible
truth we don't know given that
what are the lessons that people should
take from history it sounds like a very
damning indictment of reading history as
a a tool for understanding really
anything except the stuff that's already
happened you know the other is there
anything that you can take from this
that is actually instructive for where
you live now oh yes absolutely uh and
that's that's what motivates me that's
why I get ahead of bed in the morning
because history is so much better at
helping you think about the future than
those models that I told you about
earlier which predictably get it wrong
uh what does history enable you to do it
enables you to do what I just did to
realize that the sample size of
analogies is quite large you know what's
the right analogy for the situation of
of Britain today uh don't just take the
first most convenient one that occurs to
you bear in mind that there actually are
quite a lot of countries that had
Empires at one time and then couldn't
afford them anymore and had to get rid
of them and then had to readjust to that
experience of decolonization and then
remake themselves as nation states and
you know the the range goes from the
Netherlands to Russia
and and you've got to sort of sit down
and think well let's look at all the
different countries that that went
through this which one is is the better
fit is it is it likely that Britain's is
going to end up kind of like the
Netherlands
um I think it is I think Britain in many
ways is already quite like the
Netherlands it's just that we haven't
fully you know come to terms with that
loss of status it's not so likely I
think that Britain would end up like
Russia desperately trying to get its
Imperial Groove Back even after it's
really long gone and all that's left is
this kind of stockpile of rusting
weapons so I think the lesson that I
would take the reason that I call it
applied history
is that you've got to be kind of
systematic you're really looking for
analogies
and you've got to make sure that you you
kind of comprehensive that you try to
find them all before jumping to the
conclusion that you're tempted by and
your mindset should be not oh please
confirm me in my original Prejudice my
mindset is always please get rid of my
original Prejudice and teach me
something new and interesting uh I'll
give you another example people have
been running around with their hair on
fire since 2015 2016 When Donald Trump
suddenly burst uh onto the scene as a
credible presidential candidate as
opposed to a joke figure
and it's been enormously difficult for
Liberal intellectuals academics and
journalists to make sense of the fact
that this man got to be president and
could be president again so what's the
right analogy a lot of people lazily out
of prejudice said oh he's a fascist he's
Mussolini or he's Hitler and these were
really bad analogies because you don't
need to go to interwar Europe to find
good analogies uh to understand Donald
Trump there's a populist tradition in
the United States that goes back to the
19th century there have been quite a few
characters in American history like him
with his ideas and his style who like
well people you've never heard of there
was a guy named Dennis Kearney who led
something called the Californian Workers
Party in the late 19th century and
kearney's position was that we had to
close the border and keep out building
the immigrants he actually had built the
wall as a slogan there's a cartoon
showing a wall being built across San
Francisco Harbor he was anti-chinese
that was a big part of of cuny's appeal
he was anti-elitist he was really uh
somebody who kind of relished being a
common man without any pretensions
and all the policies that Kearney stood
for including restriction of immigration
and China bashing I mean that that has
all been in American politics before but
it's been forgotten of course currently
never got to be president no populist
until Trump has succeeded in getting to
be president but we've had populists
before offering that combination of
immigration restriction and uh and Elite
bashing and you didn't need to you
didn't need to look for analogies in
into war Europe the United States is
nothing like into war Europe I mean I've
studied into war Europe if I had a time
machine and you and I got into it and we
went off to Italy in the 1920s or
Germany in the 1930s we had a day there
we'd be like this is totally different
this is like this is crazy every other
person is in a uniform
I mean the thing about Donald Trump's
America is that you hardly saw anybody
in a uniform except occasionally there'd
be somebody coming back from Afghanistan
in an airport but this is the thing that
I'm I'm constantly struck by if you
study history rigorously
you're you're constantly struck by how
unlike the mid-20th century our time is
and and yet people seem only to know
about the mid-20th century it's
sometimes as if the only history that
anybody knows is the history of you are
reading my mind I've got in front of me
Godwin's law as an online discussion
grows the probability of a comparison to
Nazis our Hitler approaches 100 many
people are quick to compare things to
Nazi Germany because it's the only
history they think they know yeah the
History Channel has a lot to uh answer
and so forth so does so does gcsc in a
level history and but it's not only in
the UK I mean there is this uh
extraordinary over emphasis on the
mid-20th century as if that's the only
history we should really bother knowing
about I mean I studied part part of my
career I spent studying that that period
but but actually think that the 17th
century is much more Illuminating if we
want to understand our time because in
the 16th and 17th century they had to
contend with a new communication
technology the printing press and it
completely changed everything
it's suddenly drastically lowered the
barrier to entry you could you could get
your thoughts out on on paper much more
easily than on an illuminated manuscript
we're living through a comparable period
in which the public sphere has
completely be transformed by technology
and yet nobody bothers studying the 17th
century outside a few Oxford and
Cambridge colleges the 17th century was
a time when mercenaries were enormously
powerful there was a guy named
Valenstein who was the progosian of the
Holy Roman Empire we can learn a lot
from that period and it's much more
interesting and Illuminating than trying
to fit everything into uh Germany 1933
uh which which is I'm afraid what we
know we now do all as you say almost in
every online discussion
what was the response like when the
print and press became widely available
what did it change what do people not
realize about what it changed and how
did governments and people that wanted
to restrict access and stuff respond
well as the printing press spread
throughout Europe from the late 15th
century into the 16th century
it was a highly decentralized technology
you really had no central control
printing presses were springing up all
over uh Germany and especially Northern
Europe and initially religious reformers
like Martin Luther said oh great now we
can get the truth about the church and
uh about Christian doctrine out and and
more effectively explain what's wrong
with today's uh Roman Catholic Church
and and that that that was certainly
true that that message spread like
wildfire in northern Europe and very
quickly uh Luther was able to convince a
great many people not only in Germany
but all the way across the channel in
England that that something had to
change and uh and so that part was right
but what Luther didn't anticipate uh was
that once you can print the Bible and
print criticism to the Roman Catholic
Church you can print anything
uh and pretty quickly people were
printing anything there's one moment
when I can't remember where it was now
uh there's a town in South Germany where
they say can we can we print a
translation of the Quran
and Luther goes
um yeah I guess I guess so because if we
print it then people will see how false
it is uh but before long there are
people publishing tracts about how to
identify witches
you know how to spot a witch there's a
whole best-selling book uh are designed
to help you identify the witches who
live amongst us and these tracts about
witchcraft lead to the so-called witch
craze a crazy uh persecution wave
directed it perfectly innocent uh people
mostly women that led to mass executions
in all kinds of Parts uh of Europe and
Beyond Europe and in the American
colonies so the unintended consequence
of the printing press was that you you
not only disseminated
serious uh discussion of how to reform
the Roman Catholic Church you also
disseminated all kinds of crazy stuff uh
like there are witches amongst us and we
need to we need to kill them so I think
that's a really important lesson like
the internet the printing press allowed
crazy stuff to go viral because given
the choice between reading about
consubstantiation and transubstantiation
or witches
yeah you can see why a lot of people
would say can I have the book about
witches because I kind of I'm not that
interested in transubstantiation but
witches so I think that's that's one
very obvious way in which the printing
press had unintended consequences you
have 130 years of religious Warfare
after the printing press stops being
used to disseminate religious ideas
because not long before the Catholics
are publishing their tracks saying that
Luther's a heretic and he too should be
killed so yeah I mean there was a pretty
obvious lesson to be learned about the
internet from the printing press
but if you went to Silicon Valley as I
did in 20 when did I move 2016
what really amazed me was the utter
optimism that prevailed everywhere that
the internet was awesome and all its
consequences would be awesome and if
everybody was connected that would be
awesome and I mean I'm like but there
could be some downsides to connecting
everybody have you considered that like
why
but if you have an entire community of
people who don't know any history at all
and and that would never cross their
minds which is why you know people were
surprised and shocked when crazy stuff
started to go viral on on social media
spectral evidence was one of the most
interesting things I learned about when
looking at the witch trials that
um they were using this spectral
evidence which was essentially like
hysterical eyewitness testimony done
done to a poltergeist in the room that
said yes she is actually a witch and
these things have been going on for
months maybe even years and then they
got in contact somehow with the head
court or whatever the equivalent was
there the biggest magistrate in America
and they said this um we've been doing a
lot of these cases based on spectral
evidence that's um that's all right
isn't it that's that's okay
sorry what the [__] is spectral evidence
uh so yeah that was one thing that came
to mind another was um was it Thomas
Blackmore Thomas Blackburn the first
person to translate the original Bible
from Latin into the common language in
the UK and he was very quick he
persecuted and killed and one of the
reasons for that was that if you no
longer need to have the priest as your
conduit between yourself and God if you
have a personal relationship there is a
massive loss of control there a huge
loss of control because they are no
longer the vector the the middle bit of
The Hourglass that you're getting
squeezed through on your way out to
about the Reformation was the idea that
that people should be able to read
scripture themselves in a language uh
that they understood rather than having
it read to them in Latin that was a
revolutionary idea and
I think that the lesson is that one
should not expect
that kind of radical change in the
boundaries of knowledge
to have only good consequences
Mass literacy had many good consequences
I'm sure unquestionably that the
benefits exceeded the costs of mass
literacy we know they did because in in
parts of Europe where the Reformation
succeeded and literacy rates went up
economic growth was much higher over the
succeeding 300 years so net benefits
were great but there were costs too to
suddenly going from a basically
illiterate Society to a illiterate one
and I think in our thinking about the
internet and this should also inform our
understanding of artificial intelligence
we need to be more aware of the likely
costs of drastic changes in the
structure of the public sphere
what other
areas of History do you wish that we
could if if we take this entire pie of
people's history knowledge 99.5 percent
of which is taken up with Nazi Germany
uh other than 16th 17th century and
freedom of access to information and
propagation of information what are the
other big chunks that you wish that more
people knew about
well the interesting thing is that even
if you had a kind of Ideal curriculum a
school or university
it would still omit a huge percentage of
human history because you know most of
the people in history LED unrecorded
lives in uh in non-literate agricultural
societies
and so
with the best will in the world it's
really hard to recapture the human past
we're inevitably going to capture this
really unrepresentative sample which
over represents the the literate and the
urban
I think if I were designing a curriculum
for my 11 year old son
I would attempt to make it
much broader in its chronological and
geographical scope than is available in
any school today I would rather that he
knew a little bit about everything
uh than that he knew everything about
the rise of Hitler
uh Thomas who is 11 came across a
terrific
uh video online which I think Bill wurtz
did which is a complete history of the
world as a kind of
crazy musical animation it's really good
uh it's better than Yuval Noah Harare
because it's funny
and I I wish I could I remember the
exact URL uh I would give it to you all
but I'm sure if you Google kind of Bill
Works total history of the world you'll
get something and what I love about that
video is it just does everything uh
including the Phoenicians uh the Central
Asian carnates it kind of does its best
to give you a pretty comprehensive
overview and when you do it that way you
realize that most history is as I said
earlier it's kind of Empires but in all
kinds of strange places I mean let's not
pretend it was only people in Western
Europe who did Empire they were really
late to the Empire game everybody else
would be doing Empires for centuries
including Africans including the Incas
and the Aztecs Empire is actually the
standard form of of historical uh polity
and it's it's everywhere uh and and
that's that's what I would love to be
able to do my ideal history course is
just called Empires it's just like all
the empires let's try and understand
them all let's realize they're basically
everywhere they mostly do slavery to
varying extents
um they have very varied durations they
have different business models but
that's kind of what history is and there
should be some much better Grand unified
theory of of Empire than we have I was I
was in Santa Fe a couple of weeks ago at
the Santa Fe Institute hanging out with
my favorite physicist Jeffrey West who's
a brilliant guy he did a book called
scale that everybody should read and we
have this kind of pipe dream that will
join forces and and kind of do Empires
sort of for physicists and then all of
history will be intelligible
uh maybe not in a bill Works video but
in a course that will give you a sense
of just the kind of weird biodiversity
of History it's kind of strange it's
strange it's a strange Menagerie this
Zoo full of Empires some of them are
giant like elephants some of that tiny
like mice and that that's that's kind of
Jeffrey West's take on the natural world
I think it probably applies to the
historical world too so watch this space
that's my next big project it's got me
thinking about this stat I learned UH 60
of Americans don't own a passport
and when you live on a in a country
which is essentially a continent and has
you know 50 little countries all
attached that will allow you to use your
currency and speak your language and go
and work there if you want to then I
guess a bit of a justification is why
would you need to
um but the lack of worldliness I do
think contributes to uh myopia
um in America and I wonder whether
there's almost like a
a temporal myopia as well that is it's
something similar if you only know the
last hundred years of history and of
that last hundred years you really only
know 10 years between like 1935 and 1945
you
end up trying to retrofit
things that are happening now to a very
small number of examples and perhaps
broadening broadening that level of
Education would
add a little bit of ballast or
stabilizer to some of the conversations
we're having
imagine if there were time machines like
uh airbuses and you could go to the
airport
and just fly to the destination in the
past of your choice
uh the problem with tourism is that it
often gives people the impression that
they know more about the world than they
do so uh there are very many Americans
who do have passports and when they
travel uh they go to Scotland to play
golf uh and then they go uh to Paris to
have uh fancy meals or do shopping and
uh and then they'd probably go to
Florence and then they come back with
enormous
an enormous sense of their own knowledge
of Europe
uh but if all you know about Scotland is
golf uh you should watch the movie
Trainspotting five times as a kind of
corrective I think it might be the same
with time travel like everybody would be
like let's go to 1933. oh yes let's go
to 1933 and see Hitler come to power
again uh it'll it'll kind of give us a
terrible feeling of of nausea and then
we'll come come home or you know where
else would people want to go if they
were Time Travelers it's like let's go
back to the let's go back to the
swinging twenties and get drunk with
Scott Fitzgerald to be like there'll be
a bunch of destinations that would be
really popular and I'd be that one guy
on the little plane going to the Peace
of West failure in 1648 it's like I
think you should go to the piece of
Westphalia in 1648 and find out how they
stop the 30 years walk because we need
something like that soon uh in the world
today but but yeah I mean time machines
I think a lot about time machines
because we don't have them never have
them I suspect and that means the only
kind of time travel we can do is
basically by reading history or we can
go and see movies which are actually
worse because you know you can go and
see Oppenheimer but he'd be better off
reading the book If you really want to
understand what happened but yeah we we
can sort of do time travel with books
and and movies uh but I suspect it's a
bit like tourism we all go to the same
places and come back with an exaggerated
sense of our own knowledge yeah I had
this conversation the other day with a
friend who was telling me about
Afghanistan in
the sort of maybe like three four five
hundred A.D and that it was a Bastion of
maybe physics and Mathematics and a few
other places and we were discussing this
sort of weirdness with history that we
kind of know unless we do invent a time
machine we know all of the things that
we're going to know about history there
are maybe some texts somewhere that are
hidden there are maybe some
archaeological digs that can be done
there are inferences that can be drawn
but when we're looking at you know
original Source material we've captured
at least a large portion probably of
what we're going to be able to capture
so it's really it's really like going
over a crime scene with very limited
evidence and it got me thinking about
you know just how different our world
would be if the Library of Alexandria
hadn't been burned if we hadn't lost a
load of this stuff to some Islamic
Crusades against some heretical
knowledge as well
or how different it would be if all of
the ancient learning had been lost uh I
mean that that's a counter factual that
I think a lot about because if all of
the ancient Athenian and Roman texts had
had been lost there would have been no
Renaissance and it's hard to imagine
quite how what we think of as Western
Civilization would have been would have
been possible or maybe we'd have had all
those ideas all over again I'll give you
a good example as a counter a point to
Afghanistan as a a place that wasn't a
basket case
Scotland if you had gone there in the
17th century would have been just like
Afghanistan today because in Scotland in
the 17th century uh it's kind of Warring
Mountain tribes religious Fanatics
extreme Calvinists control the capital
Edinburgh they're cons it's incredibly
violent had one of the most
mind-blowingly high homicide rates much
higher than any American city today next
Chicago looked like uh the Garden of
Eden and and so 17th century Scotland
looks like Afghanistan and then and it's
a very mysterious process but in the
space of a few decades you go from the
1745 Jacobite Rising Civil War Carnage
to the enlightenment to Scotland being
one of the great centers of intellectual
innovation of the late 18th century and
uh you know Walter Scott writes a great
novel perhaps the greatest historical
novel Waverly really addressing this
question how on Earth does Scotland go
from being Afghanistan to being Athens
in this really short space of time and I
still think that's one of the most
interesting questions because if it's
possible to to stop being Afghanistan
kind of actually become a center of of
not only intellectual Innovation but
economic dynamism the Adam Smith
Scotland I mean the Adam Smith Scotland
is just a couple of decades after the
Battle of Culloden uh you know that's
that's to me one of the most amazing
examples in history of total
non-linearity total discontinuity
radical upgrade from you know Civil War
to Enlightenment if it's possible in
17th century Scotland 18th century
Scotland then it should be possible in
21st century Afghanistan what are your
predictions for the next
five to ten years in terms of what we're
going to see popular politics in America
I know I've heard you say not super long
ago that you felt that a lean toward
conservatism seems not unlikely
um but we've got different forces and
different defense mechanisms on both
sides for something like Trump uh or or
even anything that looks remotely like
him so what's your
lick your finger put it in the air what
are you what are you tasting on the Wind
well I think uh let me try and apply my
my methodology uh of of rigor here
rather than just taking the first
analogy off the shelf
I think that uh the Biden presidency
uh is kind of unlikely to be a two-term
presidency
uh in the same way that uh Gerald Ford
and Jimmy Carter and George Bush Senior
could only be one-term presidents I feel
Joe Biden's a one-term president
now in that
case and by the way the economics and
the polling all would substantiate the
fact that he's not in a strong position
to get reelected
that means the Republican nominee is
quite likely to win
but the Republican nominee right now is
quite likely to be Donald Trump uh he's
far ahead of the competition Ron
DeSantis isn't really getting much
traction and and so we are in The
Amazing situation that a man who has
just been indicted of trying to overturn
the last election
and that's just one of the many criminal
charges he faces right now
uh could be re-elected
uh and it's not the it would be the
second time in American history that
somebody had two non-consecutive terms
Grover Cleveland did it in the late 19th
century
I think the probability of trump coming
back is much higher than most people
realize right now
uh because just as in 2015 uh people
struggled to imagine Trump uh being
president the first time they struggle
again
uh with the kind of cognitive barriers
to to giving that a high probability
so I'm kind of
struggling to see what stops him now
unless the Democrats panic and persuade
Biden not to run early next year and
parachute in Gavin Newsom I think if
they do that Trump won't win because
Americans will see an old guy and a
young guy
a young kind of good looking guy though
I'm not sure how good looking but
they're kind of going to choose the
young guy uh regardless of the fact that
he's left California a kind of wasteland
so I think if Biden's the nominee all
the way through uh Trump could win and
then we will have an extraordinary time
in American history because the left
will will refuse to acknowledge that
result just as much as Trump refused to
acknowledge his defeat and the Republic
will become very politically unstable
under those under those circumstances
just to come back to my Roman point
it's not really the Roman Empire that
the United States is like it's the Roman
Republic that it's like and Republican
institutions historically have not been
fantastically long-lived most republics
in history have not been long-lived uh
it's only relatively recently that we
had long-lived republics and uh any
political theorists from the ancient
world or the Renaissance or the
enlightenment would have said well
republics tend not to last because at
some point they either choose a tyranny
or they descend into uh corruption and a
demagogue comes to power all of the
processes that we see at the moment at
work would not surprise uh traditional
political theorists so I think the
Republic has more to worry about than if
you like than the Empire and you know if
Trump is is re-elected
I shall I shall be quite glad to be
sitting safely in England watching it
from a distance I'm not sure I'd want to
be here if that happened well that would
get I think that could get very nasty I
could get very nasty
I'm kinetic nasty yeah yeah because I
mean they'll take to the left will take
to the street so Donald Trump is
re-elected they will become the election
deniers at that point and I think the
Trump second Trump Administration will
be ruthlessly well prepared for power in
a way that the first Trump
Administration wasn't so
yeah that's my kind of that's my crystal
ball so far as I like it it's
interesting I I definitely think there
is a case of
um Tit for Tat an Ever escalating Tit
for Tat rebuttal the same as anybody
that's had a little bit of an argument
with their partner and and one evening
you came home late and the next morning
you there was a nasty note read saying
hope you had a good night like and
there's no milk in the fridge and and
then you have to sleep in the spare room
for a couple of days or whatever
um and then the next time that the your
partner does that you remember that you
keep it in the back of your mind and you
think oh maybe I wasn't so bothered
about this or maybe this wouldn't have
have triggered in my mind but I'm
actually they they did this to me so I'm
gonna do it to them so I'm gonna Stick
it to them and I do feel like
um one of the
Echo uh uh sort of cyclical uh
replicating trends that was created with
the uh pushback that Trump gave to the
election results three years ago uh is
okay all right well that's that's now on
the table that is a discussion which is
on the table election dinner and as soon
as anybody says how can you be doing
this people from the left were you not
the ones that were saying that this
should have been accepted and the left
will say well were you not the ones that
said that this could have never happened
how are you are you do you not storm the
capital Did you not deny
and it's this like super juvenile uh you
hit me last type game and uh yeah I I do
worry about what doorways that opens in
future
well that's why monarchies turn out to
be more stable than republics because
you have a personification of uh of the
state that is above partisan politics
that in the Republic it's all uh or
nothing bipartisan conflict and
I think if one looks back at the 19th
century American politics was a contact
sport then it's gone back to being a
contact sport after a period when there
was a certain gentlemanly bipartisanship
at least for periods of the 20th century
and that that's gone and we're now back
into the kind of contact sport that
Dickens writes about when he visits the
United States so
the tip for tap thing is important um
from a republican Vantage Point
Democrats didn't expect accept the
legitimacy of Trump's victory
uh in 2016. although that's uh that's
often forgotten there was a great uh
wave of protest against uh Trump in his
first year including if you remember the
women's March
uh the the great I think critical moment
uh has arrived when
many Americans think that a double
standard has been applied that that
Trump was targeted by the justice system
and the bidens were given treat
treatment that was quite different and
that's a really important shift that's
happening in American politics right now
Joe Biden is an extroably losing his
Amtrak Joe regular guy image because of
his son and his involvement with his
son's business dealings and the more
that happens the more people will say
well there's nothing really to choose
between them you can say what you like
about Donald Trump but they're all
corrupt they're all crooked and that
that's going to be important I think in
the Final Phase of the election next
year when it will be decided by
independent voters and swing voters in a
small number of states and indeed in a
small number of counties because that's
how machine politics works most States
and most counties are already already
predictable but a small number or not
and I think those arguments about double
standards uh will count for a lot much
more than arguments about whether the
2020 election was stolen it's the sense
that a double standard has been applied
that will help Trump
now as I said
concluding reflection
history is not
really capable of giving you a crystal
ball it doesn't allow you to say with
any real
confidence who win the next election
even though it's less than 18 months
away
but if you start playing the game of
pattern recognition you can start to see
why Biden's a weak candidate
why if he continues to seek re-election
he could be a one-term president and why
under those circumstances Donald Trump
despite uh all that happened on January
the 6th 2021 could get reelected that's
all I'm saying
Neil Ferguson ladies and gentlemen I
really really love your energy Neil I
love your your Insight in feeling very
balusted and stabilized now after
learning about some stuff that I didn't
from history what are you working on
next what should people expect from you
and how can they keep up to date with
those things Volume 2 of my biography of
Henry Kissinger I'm working on that uh
every waking hour except when I'm doing
podcasts it's really good and uh and and
that will be the next book that I I
publish while you're waiting for that
you can buy Doom the politics of
catastrophe which was the book that I
published most recently A couple of
years ago now and regular readers of my
column which appears for Bloomberg
opinion can hear my thoughts every two
weeks when I when I drop a column there
well I appreciate you very much thank
you cheers Chris if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe